чає суккур шматок хліба і вина з співає
на дугу
іришка на я кому можна про знайшла там з
ран куди ви дайте 5
такі розуми вижити а в тему комунальному
про тулку послуг янського пораниш цей
ведмедик вище за місяць або без харченка
а з початком збродженого конфлікту на
донбасі мерія підібгав аскарова щось сюди
нових без хадж енакін тягачів литвин і
50 та 8 річкові олександром та kool-aid
штату porsche та
3 повстання місяць ерін пробу або карниз
луганська куди і газу сколково ми пураны
ним і до правові українські вся кава
чує Чернухіне луганської області у
лютова друк обстрілявши снаряд покращив у
його пляшок Олександр вірш вискочить і
олега сестра не
цей документ документ і додасть новий
тен і power 5 туди землянки на мій
поставлю буду жидами житиму цілу годину
і менш капітал я шукав на та пак
постраждав їхні довгі кіл тут ми на
будь-яку руку і йшли бої - рік а нормальний
вигляд буду це місце так і не пішов і в
депутати естради слов'янського диму рус
побачиш щоб з тілом бюджеті вселяти на
вигляд буду ви про ватного сектору німа
наш концерт з добий кроку люди пуховику
до допомагає сбу 23 аллан і міс civic
клієнта
благочиння фонди церкви якщо ми говоримо
про ватний 40 турцію наш головний бен
ладена видна була небагата поверх його
що з ну я на простягніть руку тигрів і
малим зебу тис у бюджеті продаю ми
доб'ємося щоб їх видно було з приватним
сектором для відразу мило що буду а ось
приватним сектором зовсім немає
розуміння що відбудеться розрив у висновок
і на державу фінансово не вигляд буду в
об'єкт у приватної влади а тут у
Сема і Невський біт 6 навряд чи варто
поважаючи юрист Андрій Кристинка
за українським законодавством вам навіть вам
вже наша компанцева від надлишку це вище
за рішенням суду піди вниз коріння ж
стала надходить і на тереці до
українських суддів aleah їжу європейському
суду заправлю ден і за статистикою нас
видно зростанням 100 тис такий я заспівав з
приблизно 500 скарб просто україною русі
обидва убог державу відразу
стасу та тяпу день на сході україни топ
то весь кого конфлікту і наблизив 42
сотки в cisco rf
з тусується захисту приватної влади
захисту власності
андрей кристинку залишимося сам відвезли в
багата в районі донбасу і ки україна
повернула піци контроль видно в чи
вільні та роботи прикрашеному випад q
видути сатирики на стратегічних
об'єктах на самому ширяють над їх що
важливі для армії
юристу з'являлися що так поки що на
донбасі місяць і типу стріл і
червні великий до цілісності масштабного
видно в лоні я донбасу все б яйця на
виду масті грошей не вистачає гарний
навіс тачаю держави не нащел у принципі
на мага тис оплати простіше в регіонах та
потенційно може бути вибухового на і
держава не налагоджується дохід вже не
вирішуються спочатку тягу руку депутата
дунайську біля рада проголосувала за
вивів і не 300 мільйонів гривень на вигляд
буду вислав я шукав гру сюди миска і
скарбниці члена дешевий на мої кішки та на
петрівку робочого стану
вибухового іншу воду воду і
каналізації давайте тисяч мишу каємося і
слов'янська
вже інший місяць постіль відривати воду
вище за графіком вручена видно у неї
воду слухняності відсікає села шию віри
сні комунальник вона знає з чого під
шина ти замість вигляд депутати на магазин
внизу ватої волонтерські бригади на вигляд
буду ви is the vision сіки машкович
чому при користі так ходять на такі
роботи та ноги просто за гарячий убитий
прозваний теж ти приніс ти park on days
по фарму вату ті, що шукають беню, прочекаємо а
чим вона закінчиться закінчиться на
прикиньте травм я ситуація на донбасі
знав за рік будувалася а втікає живе
обстріл мишкою this навчилася глашатай
свій серпанок зоні бойових дій проти
укутаний days залишиш і умови пекельну
сигурд вже тканина повна knives and cry
впасти і ніс велику вітру ти здаси
бюджету на компенсації біженців за
шизоафективним і даного уряду їх же
близько мільйона 200 тисяч вусик за рахунок
місяця викачувати навіть бюджету очищена
менше 900 меню не українською і тягну одна
причина від шуму в державі на моїх вух
на масштабний вигляд буду гудрун
он їх районі ви не встигаєте вигляд буду
виведення з вийду виделкою та машканти
слов'янська ду лінії фронту злитися 60
кілометрів люди бояться що винам уже
повернутися судини
буде яким ці